la caisse de dépôt a dévoilé ses
résultats pour la première partie de
l'année 2021 rendement de 5,6 pour cent
ses supérieurs à son indice de référence
l'actif net a grimpé et les revenus
fixes de laquelle sont el cheikh
rendement négatif de 1,8 pour ça avec la
chute de valeur des obligations
au moment où les taux montent les actifs
réels qui comprennent les immeubles les
infrastructures ont généré un rendement
de plus de 4% les actions avec les
bourses notamment et les placements
privés rendement de plus de 12% la
caisse qui dit poursuivre son
repositionnement de son portefeuille
immobilier en vendant des centres
commerciaux des bureaux traditionnels
aussi pour miser sur la nouvelle
économie alors on en parle ce soir avec
charles hey man qu'on a plaisir
d'accueillir le pdg de la caisse de
dépôt et placement du québec bon soir
monsieur bonsoir monsieur clients alors
près de 4,5 milliards d'actifs
maintenant chaque fois je vous rappelle
le gros chiffres et bien sûr la caisse
s'est beaucoup de types
d'investissements placement privé les
obligations mais pas seulement la bourse
mais n'empêche la bourse a quand même
monté de 14 à 16% depuis le début de
l'année comment on place votre rendement
de 5,6 dans ce contexte là il faut
toujours se rappeler qu'on a des
déposants qui ont des politiques de
placement avec un certain niveau de
risque à l'intérieur desquels on doit
opérer donc on a deux marchés boursiers
on a tous les grands portefeuilles dans
le monde évidemment le marché canadien
est allé jusqu'à 18% les marchés
émergents 4 5% lundi ce mondial dans le
milieu à 9% portefeuille marchés
boursiers mais était 2% au-dessus de
tout ça un indice à neuf et notre
rendement était à 11.4 pour ça alors il
s'inscrit bien quand on compare juste
les marchés boursiers avec les indices
boursiers on a plein d'autres actifs
pour avoir rendement/risque diversifiées
pour répondre aux besoins de nos
déposants et là le message que vous avez
envoyé est ce que ce qu'on a constaté
notamment et la presse en parlait ce
matin le document de la securities and
exchange commission que vous devez
déposer de l'information - de bach moins
d'investissements dans les titres
bancaires moins d'investissements dans
les pétrolières mais plus deux géants du
web comme facebook amazon à porte dans
vos actifs pourquoi cette stratégie là
je pense une question de dosage en étant
une période de reprise alors tout ce qui
était un peu là je dirais procyclique on
demeure exposée aux banques canadiennes
mais comme j'avais déjà dit on avait je
pense un peu de rattrapage à faire au
niveau des nouvelles technologies de la
nouvelle économie évidemment les les les
titres gars femmes les grands géants
sont souvent
l'explication que les gens leurs
recherches pour voir les mouvements mais
ce que je dirais on a doublé notre
exposition là mais on demeure un peu en
mode 'l'indice donc on y va avec dosage
où on va pascoal exactement puisque son
d'évaluation élevés mais sont des titres
qui ont très bien performé double à peu
près du rendement du portefeuille
marchés boursiers alors c'est je pense
une stratégie gagnante tout en restant
que posait des banques par exemple sont
très fortes comme on le fait avec des
hausses de près de 100% dans la phase de
reprise mais est ce que votre retrait
quand même partielle des banques au
cours des derniers mois a été précipitée
parce que quand je regarde l'évolution
la royale de la td de la bmo là en
hausse de 20 à 30% depuis le début de
l'année pour comprendre que cette ce
balancement là s'est fait beaucoup plus
tard à la fin donc non on a réussi à
vraiment bénéficié de cette exposition
là c'est plutôt très récents comme comme
rebalancement du portefeuille au niveau
des banques est ce qu'un portefeuille
immeuble qui a quand même connu une
année 2009 particulièrement difficile
qui on passe aux centres commerciaux
est-ce qu'il est à point est ce qu'il
est restructurée est-ce que vous avez
terminé la restructuration de ce
portefeuille
j'avais dit l'année dernière quand on a
entamé ce repositionnement lequel reste
trois étapes arrêter le déclin renverser
la tendance et stabiliser le
portefeuille je voudrais qu'on est en
avance sur notre plan après un honneur
sur trois ans je dirais qu'on est à peu
près aux deux tiers monsieur fillon qui
reste probablement une autre année un
peu de travail à abattre mais c'est un
portefeuille qui a changé déjà
significativement 5 milliards de
transactions au cours des six derniers
mois 5 milliards de transactions oui et
je vous dirai pour vous donner une image
et centres commerciaux représentait à
peu près 1 9 1 6 % du portefeuille
immobilier est maintenant à 16 pour ça
de l'autre côté la logistique un secteur
porteur avec le commerce en ligne on en
a autant que les centres commerciaux
doit alors qu'on en avait moins que 10%
et à 16% dans la logistique alors c'est
un portefeuille qui est sur des assises
beaucoup plus solide dans les secteurs
payant est-ce que la hausse boursière à
laquelle on assiste sauf peut-être de
jour là mais la hausse boursière
s'essouffle pour vous est-ce que les
gains qu'ils étaient à faire sur la
reprise sur l'abondance de capital note
des banques centrales notamment est-ce
que ça commence à être chose du passé
pour vous écouter il ya plusieurs
facteurs qui sont en jeu c'est certain
que quand on regarde débuté milieu de
cycle fin de ces scellés même scellé
même pattern si vous me permettez
l'expression
mais son fait de beaucoup façon beaucoup
plus concentrés alors c'est comme sont
en très bientôt alors à la fin de la du
cyclo je dirais deux reprises pour
rentrer dans un milieu dont il offre
peut-être une rotation sectorielle et
vous en parlez plutôt de vos invités ou
dans le reportage qu'est ce que les
banques centrales ou comment ils vont
faire atterrir tout ça avec une vélocité
de la reprise qui va ralentir une
économie encore forte mais la croissance
votre argument ralentir et en toile de
fond des pressions inflationnistes alors
comme un cri la durenque ben c'est un
élément qu'on surveille sur notre radar
parce que notre vie est encore que ce
sont des pressions temporaires mais
néanmoins certains éléments exogènes je
suis d'accord ce que votre invité du
préalablement on prend même le delta le
delta le variant delta pardon ça peut
être un élément qui sera ramenée à une
contraction pas du tout comme mon avis
qu en 2020 mais que ça peut créer
parfois des goulots d'étranglement dans
certaines chaînes d'approvisionnement
mais ça pourrait faire persister un peu
plus longtemps l'inflation même son
crois que le but c'est que l'inflation
la hausse actuelle et l'or sur une base
temporaire mais certains signaux sur le
tableau indicateur qu'on surveille de
près les tensions géopolitiques
sont toujours présentes même elles se
sont exacerbées que ce soit la chine et
les états unis
notamment sa plein d'autres endroits le
reste réglementaire c'est clairement un
élément pour nous qui est qui est
important est qu'on tient compte dans
tous nos investissements maux sur leur m
en terminant le réseau express
métropolitains qui vont entrer en
activité l'été prochain le travail le
télétravail va réduire de 10 %
l'achalandage prévu avez-vous dit
aujourd'hui est ce que ça pourrait
affecter la rentabilité
envisagée du rem pour la caisse la
réponse est non vous savez ce 10% alors
c'est dans un premier temps c'est quand
même des projets qui s'inscrivent sur 50
ans la thèse d'investissement le besoin
d'avoir un mode de transport de mobilité
durable à montréal est toujours
nécessaire et je donnais soit comme un
estimer quand on compare qui va du
bureau à la résidence n'est pas tous les
déplacements d'un projet comme ça qu'ils
sont juste pour ce type de déplacement
alors c'est pas tout le monde non plus
qui est en télétravail en attendant ce
we à l'admettre c'est là pour rester
mais beaucoup de gens doivent et devront
se déplacer pour aller au travail donc
une robustesse au niveau de nos
projections on prévoit aussi des hausses
dans le temps sur son horizon temps
alors pour nous il n'y a pas de danger
ce niveau là en terme de rentabilité
pour notre institution charlie bon merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
aujourd'hui merci monsieur finir pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici et redit